Booking.com, this is Brad speaking.
How may I help you?
Ah, you're locked out of your hotel in the middle of the night after a 12-hour flight?
Ah, I see. Okay, so you've booked a hotel in Manchester, Vermont instead of Manchester, England.
So, they gave you a view of the kitchen instead of the mountains?
Don't worry, we'll sort it out for you.
Anytime, anywhere, we're there...
...to wow our customers with our top-notch personal service in more than 40 languages.
And guess what?
We're looking for new faces to join us in our mission.
Being a customer service executive is an exciting job,...
...requiring full commitment and the right mindset.
You are the customer's personal connection to the company.
Customers are counting on you to be there each and every time.
So, are you a born problem solver with smart and fast solutions in the heat of the moment?
Are you a superhuman communicator with a passion for friendly service?
And are you an ace in English on top of your mother tongue?
It's the operating language of the company, so you need to be fluent.
If you are, you can find yourself with the most varied job on the planet,...
...working with international colleagues across the globe.
And a whole world of people only a call or a click away,...
...looking forward to meeting you.